TO ORDER RESPONSE COBIT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER T ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS. THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR HEARING IN THE
CHAMBER WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. THE MEMBER ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY A SENATOR STERN
SENATOR IF YOU HAVE A STAFF
PERSON WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE
PLEASE IDENTIFY THAT STAFFER
NINE. SENATOR MISTER CHAIR AT
ITS CHEER ME WHILST MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN PLUS CENTER IS A REMINDER
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER THAT WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY COULD STICK
FEEDBACK I S. THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM I KNOW YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
UNMUTE. PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN WHEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE- TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
BRIEFING ROOMS. TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
TESTING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WAS. WHICH TESTIFIED. TODAY
PRO INDIVIDUALS WISHING PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED. ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT. NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT SEVEN SIX EIGHT
NINE FOUR ONE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
A MODERATOR DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE THEY'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. HE'S
NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE. YOU'RE WATCHING ON
IT IN THE HEARING OF WATCHING
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE HEARING. FROM THE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS OF MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS. THE
DOCTOR HEARINGS AND IS CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. MAYBE SOME LAG TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN BE
HEARD. BUT DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS- THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED MAY INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT
OF TIME WHICH IS TO WITNESSES
FOR TWO MINUTES EACH ALL THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
THEIR AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES I WANNA MAKE IT
CLEAR UP FRONT DEVELOPMENT EACH
SIDE SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TO
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS AGAIN WILL ONLY
BE ALLOWED TESTIFIED FOR TWO
MINUTES- EACH SIDE WILL HAVE A
MAX OF TWENTY MINUTES FOR
WITNESSES WHO MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMON SURNAMES AFFILIATION AND
POSITION LET ME UNDERLINE THIS
SO THAT. WITNESSES BEYOND THE
INITIAL TWO WITNESSES THEN THEY
MAY ONCE THEY'RE ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE THEY MAY STATE
THEIR NAME. THEY MAY STATE
THIR AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION ALL FURTHER COMMENTARY
WILL BE CUT OFF. WE HAVE SIX
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA TO
WHICH ON CONSENT. BEFORE WE
pLET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM- MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I WILL THE SENATOR'S
PLEASE TURN YOUR MICROPHONES ON.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM UMBERG HERE-
BURKE HERE BORJAS PRESENT.
PORTIS PRESENT ZERO HERE THE
BATTLE HERE THE RUSSELL HERE
DID US SO HERE GONZALEZ HERE
GONZALEZ HERE HERTZBERG HERE
HERTZBERG HERE JONES. LAYERED
HERE LAYERED HERE STERN. STRONG
HERE. STERN HERE WHITE CAL SKI
HERE WHY CASKEY HERE WIENER.
WIENER CAN YOU TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. WIENER PRESIDENT
WINNER PRESENT- YOU HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU WITH A NOTICE
OF SETTLEMENT OF A QUORUM FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS IS THE
ADOPTION OF OUR COMMITTEE RULES
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION THE RULES
ARE ADOPTED. NOW LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR THERE
ARE TWO ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP
THREE ZERO EIGHT BY SENATOR
MEN. AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
THREE TWO NINE BY SENATOR JONES
WHO IS A COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO
JUST TO NOTING FOR THE RECORD.
SO JONES- HAS TO BE PRESIDENT
OF THE COMMITTEE HEARING YOU
WHO WE CAN BE RETURNING LATER
ON- DURING THIS HEARING- IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONCEPTUAL- THE SERVER
HERTZBERG MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- MENTIONED COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS FOUR AND
FIVE- BURKE. BY ABOUT THEM
BURKE BY. LARGEST FOUGHT. FOR
DEATH I HAVE A LITTLE BY.
LITTLE I DID ALSO. THE RUSSELL
I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. LAYERED ON A LAYERED I
STERN STRONG. STERN I Y. CASKEY
HI WHY CASKEY I WIENER. WIENER
HI YOU HAVE TEN TWO ZERO
HOLDING THE WORLD OPEN. ALREADY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A- WE'RE
GOING TO PROCEED IN A FILE
ORDER C. CENTER LEYVA HERE BUT
CENTER LEAVE IT IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO FIRST START WAS SENT A
COUPLE EUROS BILL I KNOW SHE'S
A MEMBER THE COMMITTEE BUT THAT
FOR PURPOSES OF BEING ABLE TO
HAVE WITNESSES CALL IN AT THE
RIGHT TIME. WE HAVE TO GO AND
FILE ORDER SO SENATE CABALLERO-
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT SB
TWENTY FOUR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB TWENTY FOUR WHICH
MAKES REVISIONS TO THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER FORM
TO PROTECT A CHILD'S SCHOOL
MEDICAL AND DENTAL INFORMATION
FROM AN ABUSIVE PARENT. THIS
BILL REQUIRES THIRD PARTY
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS SCHOOLS
AND OFFICES AND MEDICAL OFFICES
TO DEVELOP PROTOCOLS WHEN THEY
RECEIVE A COPY OF SUCH A COURT
RESTRAINING ORDER I WOULD LIKE
TO ADD THAT I'VE AGREED TO
STRIKE THE IMMUNITY PROVISIONS
FROM THE BILL. I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASE THAT WAS THE CATALYST FOR
SB TWENTY FOUR BEGINS WITH A
YOUNG MOTHER KELLY WHO LIVED IN
MAJOR WITH THEIR THREE YOUNG
BOYS ALL AGED UNDER SIX KELLY
LEFT HER HUSBAND IN MAY OF LAST
YEAR AFTER YEARS OF PHYSICAL.
BRUTAL PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE BECAUSE OF
THE EMOTIONAL ABUSE HE WAS
ISOLATED FROM HER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND WAS AFRAID FOR THE
SAFETY OF OUR YOUNG BOYS AND
BELIEVED THAT NO ONE WOULD HELP
HER. WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SUPPORT
SHELTER SHE OBTAINED A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER AND
WENT INTO HIDING WITH HER
CHILDREN. AND CONTACTED HER
FAMILY FOR HELP. AT SUCCESSFUL
HIDING HER HUSBAND FOR THREE
MONTHS AND GETTING HELP FOR HER
AND HER BOYS. KELLY MADE AN
APPOINTMENT AT A LOCAL HEALTH
CLINIC. THE CLINIC CALL TO
CONFIRM THE APPOINTMENT AND
CALLED KELLY'S HUSBAND CELL
PHONE. SO THAT HE INADVERTENTLY
LEARNED AT THE TIME AND THE
LOCATION OF THE IMPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT. ON JULY FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY CALLIE'S
ESTRANGED AND VIOLENT HUSBAND.
DROVE TO THE CLINIC WAITED FOR
KELLY IN THE PARKING LOT AND
WHEN SHE ARRIVED. HE SHOT AND
KILLED HER IN BROAD DAYLIGHT AS
SHE SHIELDED THEIR THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN FROM THE BULLETS. I
BRING KELLY STORY TO YOUR
ATTENTION BECAUSE IN THE REALM
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THIS LEVEL
OF CONTROL. PLANNING AND
PERPETUAL VIOLENCE IS
UNFORTUNATELY UNFORTUNATELY NOT
AN UNCOMMON OCCURRENCE IT IS
PROJECTED THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HAS RAVAGED OUR
COMMUNITIES AT EVEN HIGHER
RATES SINCE THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC. PARTICULARLY SINCE
THE STAY AT HOME ORDER WAS
ISSUED. FOR THOSE IN AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP THE RISKS THEY
FEET FACE AND LEAVING THEIR
PARTNER MAY BE JUST AS
DANGEROUS AS THE RISK OF
STAYING PUT. UP 270% SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT. OF ABUSED WOMEN
WHO ARE MURDERED OR KILLED
AFTER THEY LEAVE TEIR
PARTNER'S. VIOLENT PERPETRATORS
TO MURDER THEIR EX PARTNERS GO
TO GREAT LENGTHS TO TRACK THEIR
VICTIMS ONE STRATEGY UTILIZED
BY ABUSIVE PARTNERS. IT'S TRUE
IS TO TRACK THE LOCATION OF THE
SHARED CHILDREN. THIS IS WHY A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER IS VITAL TO SURVIVORS.
THESE PROTECTIVE ORDERS
REQUIRED THE PERPETRATOR TO
REFRAIN FROM HAVING ANY CONTACT
WITH THE VICTIMS. AND THEIR
CHILDREN. CURRENTLY A JUDGE CAN
GRANT A MULTITUDE OF DIFFERENT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE ABUSED
PARTY IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER. INCLUDING
ORDERS THAT PROTECT THE MEDICAL
AND SCHOOL INFORMATION OF THE
SHARED CHILDREN. HOWEVER WHILE
A JUDGE HAS THIS DISCUSSION
ALREADY. A JUDGE CANNOT SELECT
THIS PROTECTION ON THE ACTUAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER FORM. THEREFORE WHEN A
PROTECTIVE ORDER IS PRINTED AND
GIVEN TO THE PARTIES INVOLVED
IT DOES NOT EXPLICITLY SAY.
THAT SCHOOL- MEDICAL- DE AND-
ABOUT THE SHARED CHILDREN BE
PROTECTED FROM THE PERPETRATOR.
THIS MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR A
SCHOOL OR MEDICAL OFFICE TO
ENFORCE IF THERE IS NO CLEAR
LANGUAGE STATING OTHERWISE THEN
THE THIRTY PARTY THIRD PARTY
INSTITUTIONS WILL NOT DENY A
PARENT THE LEGAL RIGHT TO
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CHILD. SB
TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO EDIT THE
CURRENT RESTRAINING ORDER FORM
SO THAT PROTECTIVE ORDERS WILL
CLEARLY STATE WHETHER OR NOT A
JUDGE HAS ISSUED THIS
PROTECTION. THAT WAY THIRTY
THIRD PARTY INSTITUTIONS SUCH
AS SCHOOLS AND MEDICAL OFFICES
WILL HAVE NO LEGAL HAS ENDED C.
IN COMPLYING AND SENSITIVE
INFORMATION WILL NOT BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO PERPETRATORS
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY AND
SECURITY OF THE VICTIM. AND
MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO TRACK
THEM. WE HAVE TO OFFER MORE
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE LIKE
KELLY. LIKE SB TWENTY FOUR
DOES. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY IS SERRA
RODRIGUEZ KELLY'S COUSIN WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A FEW WORDS
AND ALISON KEPT PART FROM WE'VE
WHO IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS A COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU SENATE
CABALLERO- BEFORE BEGIN
TESTIMONY LET ME JUST REMIND
THOSE WHO ARE PREPARING TO
TESTIFY THAT WE'RE LIMITING
TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS FOUR MINUTES TO EACH
SIDE- AND THEN OTHERS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SIMPLY GIVE THEIR
NAME THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR POSITION- IF MISS
RODRIGUEZ IS ON THE PHONE WE'LL
START WITH MISS. SERRA
RODRIGUEZ. MISTER MODERATOR IF
OR MISS MODERATOR IF OF. MR
RODRIGUEZ IS AVAILABLE WE'LL
START WITH HER. PLEASE PRESS
STAR ZERO SO WE CAN OPEN YOUR
LINE. IF FLORIDA'S I'M SORRY GO
AHEAD OUR GENERATOR. I WAS
JUST- INSTRUCTING HER TO PRESS
STAR ZERO. WE CAN IDENTIFY HER
LINE. ALL RIGHT ARE THERE- WE
HAVE- THERAPY GETS ON THE LINE
THANK YOUNG- MISS RODRIGUEZ
PLEASE PROCEED. YES MY NAME IS
SERRA RODRIGUEZ AND I'M THAT
COUSIN OF CALLIE FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR AND
THEIR STAFF AND EVERYONE ELSE
IS HELP AND SUPPORT KELLY
BOUGHT AT THREE TWENTY FOUR.
KELLY WITH AN AMAZING PERSON I
KNOW WE ALWAYS SAY THAT ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT KELLY TRULY WAS.
SHE LIT UP A ROOM HER LAUGH BUT
STILL QUIET BETTER SMILE WITH
CONTAGIOUS. AFTER MANY YEARS OF
IT BEING. THAT THE COLD MENTAL
EMOTIONAL BEHAVIOR CALIFORNIA
REACHED OUT FOR HELP. HONESTLY
I THAT COURAGE CAME FROM BEING
A MOM. HER VIEWS- HAVE BROKERS
SO FAR BUT I THINK BEING A MOM
GAVE HER JUST A LITTLE. AS THE
IN TO SLEEP. WHEN WE HELPED HER
ESCAPE ON MAY FIFTEENTH SHE WAS
ALMOST UNRECOGNIZABLE SHE WOULD
MAKE EYE CONTACT SHE WOULDN'T
HARDLY SPEAK UNLESS YOU AFTER
SOMETHING AND EVEN THEN SHE HAD
NO OPINION AND MADE NO
COMPLAINT BUDGET COLLEGE EYES
FOR ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING BUT
WHEN SHE INTERACTED WITH HER
VOICE YOU COULD SEE HER STILL
IN THERE WE STAYED WITH THEM
FOR A MONTH AT A HOTEL AND JUST
LISTENING TO THE HORRIFIC
STORIES OF THINGS. SHE HAD HE
HAD DONE AND THINGS YOU'LL ONLY
SEE ON TV SHE WAS TOLD EVERY
DAY HER ONLY PURPOSE BUT TO
SERVE HIM BY TELLING YOU THAT
WASN'T TRUE SHE KNEW HER
PURPOSE WAS TO PROTECT YOUR
CHILDREN KELLY SAID HER BIGGEST
FEAR. AND WHAT MADE HER FINELY
WAS THAT IF SHE DIDN'T HE WOULD
KILL THEM ALL SHE WANTED TO END
THE CYCLE OF ABUSE SHE LOVED
HER CHILDREN AND DID NOT WANT.
TO EVER BE A CHANCE THAT THEY
WILL GROW UP TO BE ANYTHING
LIKE HIM SHE WANTED HER
CHILDREN TO KNOW WHEN TO LET
THE FAMILY WOULD LIKE AND WHAT
IT WAS LIKE TO BE A CAN. THE
LONGER SHE WAS FREE. THE MORE
SHE WAS WRECKED. AGAIN BOB JUST.
BUT SHE COULD WRECK. OR SO
AGAIN. SHE COULD BE. YOU CAN
SEE HER FIGHTING TO BE FREE.
SHE SMILED SHE LAUGHS SHE WAS
PLANNING A FUTURE FOR HER AND
HER KIDS WITH HER FAMILY. THE
PEOPLE SHE LOVES AND THE PEOPLE
WHO LOVE THEM. SHE WAS. ABLE TO
FINALLY TELL HER TRUTH. IN
AGING HEALING SHE WAS SO
AMAZING AND FULL LIFE AGAIN.
SHE WAS STAYING IN A WOMEN'S
SHELTER AND FILL HIM SHE WAS
EXTREMELY CAREFUL EVEN GOING TO
COURT HAD TO BE DONE WITH
CAUTION IN CERTAIN DAYS TO
PREPARE FOR. JUST A- ON JULY
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWENTY KELLY
HAD AN APPOINTMENT AT YOUR
ARENA HELP. WHERE AN EMPLOYEE
HAD TOLD HER STRANGE HUSBAND OF
HER APPOINTMENT. HE WAITED FOR
HER AS SHE EXITED THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE. IN ANY AT THE SHELTERS
BANNED. UNDER DOWN IN THE LAST
MOMENT. WITHOUT A THOUGHT SHE
PICKED UP ONE OF HER SON. YOUR
HAND IN THE VAN AND USED HER
BODY TO PROTECT THE LIVES OF
OUR CHILDREN. MUNSTER TOOK HER
FROM US JUST AS WE GOT HER
BACK. SHE'S A HERO SHE WOULD
GIVE ANYTHING TO PROTECT YOUR
CHILDREN AND ON JULY
THIRTEENTH. SHE LIVES. IT IN
THE DISTRICT THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTRUST REDUCE YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURAGE AND THANK AND WE'RE
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS- MISS KEPT
PART. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALISON
CAPPER AND THE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL SERVICES WHICH MEANS I'M
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
SACRAMENTO THAT PROVIDE.
SERVICES TO VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE- I'M ALSO A
FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY I
SUPERVISED A STAFF OF THREE
OTHER FAMILY LAW ATTORNEYS TO
PROVIDE PRO BONO LEGAL
SERVICES. TO VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS WHO ARESEEKING
PROTECTION IN FAMILY COURT.
THAT WE'VE SUPPORT SB TWENTY
FOUR AS IT WILL IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF FACT AND TO SHARE
MINOR CHILDREN WITH THEIR
ABUSER BY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
THAT ABUSERS CAN CURRENTLY
EXPLOIT SHOULD TRACK AND LOCATE
VICTIMS AND THEIR CHILDREN.
DOESN'T WHAT HAPPENED IN
KELLY'S CASE- IF THE COMMITTEE
HAS ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DVR- PROCESS. I AM
ALSO HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE.
BUT YOU MISCO PART- THIS
POWERFUL POWERFUL ISSUE LET'S
NOW SEE IF THEY'RE ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY I SEE NINE IN THE
GALLERY LET'S LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEE IF THEY'RE ANY
WITNESSES WAITING IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO TESTIFY. THAT THERE
ARE NONE- NOW WILL MOVE TO
SUPPORT WITH WITNESSES- WAITING
TO TESTIFY. BY VIA
TELECONFERENCE. MISTER MODERATE
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WHEN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY FOUR
AND WILL BEGIN AS SOON AS-
WELL- THE FIRST. WITNESS IS IN
LINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO FOR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT. AND ALIGN ELEVEN
YOUR MIND COULD OPEN. YES MANY
MANY CHRISTINE FACT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO
ANIMATE THE FILING. WELL THANK
YOU. WELL I LET THIRTEEN YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU SENATORS- THIS IS
RICK AND DIANNE BEATTIE FROM
THE L. S. ON THE AD ADVOCACY
GROUP AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
PEOPLE IN Q. PARTY- WILL GIVE
IT ANOTHER FEW SECONDS TO SEE
IF ANYONE ELSE COMES ON THE
LINE. HEY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THAT COMMAND ONE MORE TIME IS.
ONE ZERO. AND LET LET ME ASK IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NONE IN THE
GALLERY- I DON'T BELIEVE THERE
ANY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE MISTER
MODERATOR THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON. ZERO MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT IF THERE
ARE NO FURTHER WITNESSES- I'M
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER OF QUESTIONS. FROM
MEMBERS. I SEE NO NO QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS- SET A COUPLE EURO
THANKS RINGS FOR THANK YOU ALSO
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF I THINK TO A MODIFIED
IMPROVE THE BILL CYNICAL EURO.
WOULD LIKE CLOSE. VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THEM THE
HARD WORK OF THE STAFF AND IN
HELPING ME GET TO THIS POINT.
IT'S SUCH A SIMPLE SOLUTION
WHICH IS TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY ON A- ON A FORM AND
IF IT SAVES LIVES THEN IT'S
WELL WORTH IT AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. ALREADY IS OUR MOTION.
CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES THE
BILL- IT'S- REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THAT'S THE MOTION. A MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. SB TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
COVEY IT'LL AND THE MOTION IS
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG IT'S DO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG HI. I'M
BURKE I GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS HI
KELLY AT ALL BY THE WAY AT ALL
I DID ALSO. DURACELL I GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ BY HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. LAYERED HI
LAYERED I STERN STERN AYE.
STERN I WHITE HOUSE GABILEY WHY
CASKEY I WIENER. ONE NINE BILL
THE BILL IS OUT NOW THE
NINETEEN YEAR OLD. THE NINE
ZERO IS THE VOTE WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN HERE- UNTIL
THE CONCLUSION OF THE HEARING.
ALL RIGHT- NEXT I'M GOING TO
HAND THE VIRTUAL GAVEL OVER TO
SENATOR BOARD JUST- FOR
PURPOSES OF ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT MY BILL AND- DIFFERENT
THAN TYPICAL PROTOCOL ON THE
PRESENT FROM HERE IN THE ROSTER
AND THE ROSTER. IT WOULD-
MISTER CHAIR WOULD BE POSSIBLE
TO ACTUALLY GET THE GAVEL. THIS
VIRTUAL GALLAGHER IS NOT COOL
THIS REPORT IS WILL ALLOW FOR
PHOTO OPPORTUNITIES AFTERWARDS.
ALL RIGHTS. WELCOME SAID
ROMBERG ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS ON PAGE TEN COMMENT
THREE YES WE ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SENATOR- PLEASE
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB FORTY ONE
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIR IN
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK-
CHRISTIAN COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
THIS BILL IS NEARLY IDENTICAL
TO A BILL THAT WAS PRESENTED
LAST YEAR CONCERNING GENETIC
INFORMATION AND CONSUMER
PRIVACY THIS BILL WOULD
STRENGTHEN CONSUMERS CONTROL
OVER THEIR GENETIC MATERIAL
WHEN THEY PROVIDED TO A DIRECT
TO CONSUMER TESTING COMPANY-
MANY OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH- WHEN YOU PROVIDE A SALIVA
SAMPLE TO A COMPANY. THEY DO
ANALYSIS IN THE REPORT BACK TO
YOU FOR EXAMPLE IS TO YOUR
ANCESTRY MAYBE SOME OTHER
ISSUES- CONCERNING HEALTH IN
THE LIKE A CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW ALLOWS CONSUMERS TO PROVIDE
GENETIC SAMPLES TO DIRECT TO
CONSUMER GENETIC TESTING
COMPANIES TO REQUEST
INFORMATION REGARDING HOW THEIR
SAMPLES ARE BEING USED ALLOWS
THEM TO OPT OUT THIS REQUIRES
CONSUMERS TO KNOW ASK FOR THE
INFORMATION AND UNDERSTAND
SOMETIMES CONFUSING CONSENT
FORMS. OF THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT
TO MY ATTENTION THIS ISSUES
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION BY A
DIRECTIVE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE TELLING SERVICE
MEMBERS NOT TO SUBMIT THEIR
SAMPLES BECAUSE THEY MIGHT BE
USED FOR NEFARIOUS PURPOSES BY
OTHER- OTHER ADVERSARIES OF THE
UNITED STATES WHAT SB FORTY ONE
REQUIRES THESE COMPANIES
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
GENETIC SAMPLES ARE COLLECTED
USED AND DISCLOSED. TO EVERY
CONSUMER IN A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDABLE FASHION ALSO
REQUIRES THE COMPANIES TO
OBTAIN A CONSUMERS EXPRESS
INFORMED CONSENT BEFORE
COLLECTING OR USING THEIR
GENETIC SAMPLES. BEFORE STORING
IT AFTER TESTING THE CONSUMER
AND ALSO BEFORE TRANSFERRING
DISCLOSING THAT SAMPLE TO A
THIRD PARTY- WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO ENSURE THAT THIS DOES
NOT INTERFERE WITH COLD IT
TESTING. PUBLIC TESTING TESTS
RNA NOT DNA BUT THERE WERE
CONCERNS THAT THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME. OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THIS BILL FOR PURPOSES OF.
COLLECTING A COVERT NINETEEN
TESTING SAMPLES WERE WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THOSE ISSUES
ARE RESOLVED- THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY CONSUMER AND
PRIVACY ADVOCATES RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS AND LEADERS.
WITHIN THE GENETIC TESTING
INDUSTRY. PASSING IT WILL
CODIFY BEST PRACTICES AND GIVE
CALIFORNIANS THE CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY PROVIDE. WHEN THEY
PROVIDE GENETIC DATA I SHOULD
ADD THAT THAT MOST COMPANIES
ACTUALLY ARE OPERATING IN A
VERY ETHICAL WAY. SOME ARE NOT
AND THUS THE NEED FOR THE BILL-
TODAY I HAVE MISS MARIE MAHONEY
WITH CONSUMER REPORTS. I'M
HOPEFUL THAT SHE IS ON THE LINE
TO TESTIFY. YEAH. MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS
MAUREEN MAHONEY AND I'M A
POLICY ANALYST AT CONSUMER
REPORTS AND WE'RE PROBABLY
SUPPORTING SB FORTY ONE IT
WOULD PROVIDE IMPORTANT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR UNIQUELY SENSE
THE GENETIC DATA THIS DATA CAN
PROVIDE INSIGHTS INTO WHETHER
YOU OR A FAMILY MEMBER IS
VULNERABLE TO CERTAIN DISEASES
AND CONSUMERS STRONGLY VALUE
PROTECTIONS OVER IT OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND CONSUMERS HAVE SIGNED
A PETITION CALLING ON LAWMAKERS
TO ENSURE THAT THIS DATA IS
KEPT. PRIVATE AND SECURE.
MILLIONS OF CONSUMERS HAVE UC'S
TEST TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND MANY LIKELY
SOON THE STATE- IT'S COVERED BY
HYPOCRISY MY AGE. WHICH REQUIRE
CONSENT FROM A DISCLOSURE. IN
CONTRAST THE DATA COLLECTED BY
DIRECT TO CONSUMER TESTING
COMPANIES IS PROTECTED CHIEFLY
BY CITY PA WHICH PROTECTS.
WHICH PLACES NEXT TO NO
RESTRICTIONS ON SECONDARY USE
OF DATA AND THE CCP IS
RELATIVELY LIMITED ABOUT THE
SALE PROVISION MEANS THAT BY
DEFAULT COMPANIES COULD LEGALLY
SHARE THIS DATA WITH THIRD
PARTIES. BUT STILL REQUIRED
CONSENT FOR THE COLLECTION
SECONDARY USES AND DISCLOSURE
OF THE STATE ARE AND HOW THE
PROVISION TO REVOKE CONSENT AS
WELL PUTTING CONSUMERS SQUARELY
IN CONTROL. FOR ME IT HAS A
STRONG DEFINITION OF CONSENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING INTO AND
HAVE A REAL CHOICE OVER HOW
THIS DATA. CAN BE USED. ALSO AT
THE DATA SECURITY REQUIREMENTS
HELP ENSURE. THE DATA IS
PROTECTED FROM UNAUTHORIZED
ACCESS. IN LIGHT OF SECURITY
BREACHES AT GENETIC TESTING
COMPANIES IN RECENT YEARS
ALREADY STATES LIKE ILLINOIS
AND MISSOURI HAVE ROBUST
PROTECTIONS OVER THE STATE AT
THIS TIME THE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
STRONG PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AS
WELL WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. YOU MARIE MAHONEY FOR THAT
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR ONE. THE
OVER FLOWING. ARE THE THEN
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE SUPPORT WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- MOVING ON TO
LINE NUMBER TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS SAKET KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA MOVING TO FULL
SUPPORT WITH THE AMENDMENT
TAKING CANTON COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I'M A MODERATE
MUCH MODERATOR COULD YOU BE
ABLE TO TELL ME HOW MANY FOLKS
ARE ON. THE LINE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SURE RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY. ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE FORWARD. LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. REMEMBER
CATALINA SANCHEZ THE CORBIN AND
HIDE THEIR REPRESENTING THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE ANY SUPPORTED
THEM IN THE POSITION WE ARE IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AFTER THE DEBATE
AMENDMENTS AND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL CONSIDER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ONGOING DISCUSSION
THANK YOUNG. IN OUR LAST
SPEAKER IN. IN LINE EIGHTEEN
HERE MY COULD OPEN. SHE MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS IN BLACKWOOD WITH
ROOFTOP STRATEGIES INVEST ON
BEHALF OF ANCESTRY AND TWENTY
THREE ME WOULD LIKE TO THANK
CENTER- BURKE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP- TO ENSURE THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE CONTROL OVER
THEIR DATA. BY OFFERING WHAT
WILL BE THE STRONGEST GENETIC
PRIVACY LAW IN THE COUNTRY
WE'RE PLEASED TO OFFER SUPPORT.
I AND- MONARCHY PLEASE CHECK
THE LINES ONCE AGAIN MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
EVERYONE REGARDING SUPPORT FOR
FORTY ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING TO
COMMENT THANK YOU ARE HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. ANY OPPOSITION.
NINE ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO
ME WITNESSES HERE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEEING NONE- LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MARIA IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROBLEMS INDIVIDUALS.
FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND
IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS MILLION IF YOU CAME TO
MEET HIM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIANS SOUTHWEST THAT
TACK THAT. THE NATIONAL
BIPARTISAN NETWORK AND TAXI-
THAN SENIOR EXECUTIVES THAT
PROMOTES THE GROWTH OF THE
INNOVATION ECONOMY.
RESPECTFULLY TAKEN ABOUT THE
LAST MINUTE POSITION AS THE
FORTY NINE AND WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE GOAL THE AUTHORS
TO PLACE CRITICAL PROTECTIONS
AROUND DIRECT TO CONSUMER
GENETIC TESTING DATA. WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS RELATE TO HOW
THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
IMPACT HELPING MAKING TESTING.
SB THIRTY WILL. MAYBE TRYING TO
CONSEQUENCES IT RELATES TO THIS
TYPE OF INFORMATION. THE
GENETIC INFORMATION AS YOU CAN
SAM COOKE IN NINETEEN TASK.
THEY OFTEN COMPLAIN OF THE BILL
COULD INTERFERE WITH THE
LABORATORIES REQUIREMENTS
REPORT COVER NINETEEN FAST AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
PLEASE SHARE THIS INFORMATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THIS CAPTURE
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE IN
LAST YEAR'S VERSION THE BILL
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. BUT
A CRITICAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE TO THE
COMPANY TO PANDEMIC AND WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO
UNINTENTIONALLY IMPEDE THAT
AFTER. INITIALLY WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE GENETIC
DATA DEFINITION THE BILL WHICH
WILL PUT IN SCOPE INFORMATION.
THE DEFINITION IS BROAD ENOUGH
THAT IT WOULD EVEN INCLUDE AN
EMPLOYEE. IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
RESULTS OF THEIR AT HOME TASK
CORPORATE OR OTHERWISE AND WE
HAVE SPOKEN WITH DOCTORS STAFF
AND WE'RE CONFIDENT THESE
ISSUES WILL BE RESOLVED WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
IN THE QUARTER WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS IMPORTANT BUSTLED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. CUME MODERATOR-
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE. WE
HAVE ONE MORE AND IT'S FROM
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL MY APOLOGIES CHAIR- I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF GOLD FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND- HE'S ALREADY. MY
APOLOGIES- I MEAN ACTUALLY
SUPPORT A HOPEFUL FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
YOUR SUPPORT IS NOW BEING
RECLASSIFIED INTO THE SUPPORT
CATEGORY- MISTER MODERATE DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IN THE QUEUE. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO FURTHER PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE QUEUE. ALL
RIGHTS THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
WE'RE GONNA BRING DISCUSSION
BACK TO- MEMBERS- COLLEAGUES-
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- OUT OF THE GATE IS-
CENTER HERTZBERG. VERY MUCH I
WANT TO QUESTION IS THE- AUTHOR
WITH RESPECT TO THIS ISSUE OF
DARK PATTERNS. I WAS NOT HERE
TO- EXCEPT TO QUESTION WHEN
POSED YES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN STROTHER. AS
YOU WELL KNOW- THIS DEFINITION
OF DARK PATTERNS IS NOT DEFINED
IN CCPA BUT- IS INCLUDED I
SUSPECT FROM YOUR RESEARCH THAT
YOU ARE SO CHARACTERISTIC OF
DOING IN PROPOSITION TWENTY
FOUR. AND AS FAR AS I KNOW
THERE'S NO OTHER LEGISLATION IN
THE COUNTRY THAT EVEN DEALS
WITH THIS ISSUE OF DARK
PATTERNS START PATTERNS IS
BASICALLY THE WAY THAT YOU
TREAT PEOPLE TO- TO GET CONSENT
WHEN THEY REALLY AREN'T
ENGAGING CONSENSUS JUST WANTED
TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS WITH
RESPECT TO. BY THE THINKING ON
THAT THIS REFERENCED IN THE IN
THE ANALYSIS AND SECONDLY A
WHILE LATER IN SPRING IF YOU
ACCEPT THIS ALSO I KNOW SOME
REFERENCE BUT I OBVIOUSLY THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THIS LAST TIME.
AND I WANTED TO GET YOUR
INSIGHTS AS TO WHY THIS TIME
YOU THINK THAT THIS MEASURE
WILL BE SIGNED CERTAINLY IS OUR
RIGHT AS THE LEGISLATURE TO PUT
THESE MATTERS FOR THE GOVERNOR
AND THE CAN BE DONE EVERY TIME
THEY WANT TO THAT'S THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS BUT JUST
WANT TO GET YOUR INSIGHT. ON
THAT SECOND QUESTION AS WELL AS
TREND- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF. THEN HERTZBERG
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ON ALL
YOUR WORK ON PRIVACY- WITH
RESPECT TO DARK PATTERNS IN
PARTICULAR- YOU YOU ARE
PROBABLY THE EXPERT HERE ON THE
FLOOR WITH RESPECT TO DARK
PATTERNS- AND MANY OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED WHERE YOU ARE
ONLINE AND YOU SEE SOMETHING
THAT IS CONFUSING ASKING FOR
YOUR CONSENT TO DO SOMETHING
THAT YOU MAY NOT WANT TO DO IF
YOU HAD A FULL KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT THAT. DEFINITION OF DARK
PATTERNS IS TAKEN FROM
PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR- AND SO
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THAT. WILL
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT IN THE
INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE
THE WAY THAT ELIMINATES THAT.
SORT OF INTENTIONAL CONFUSION
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER ONE ITEM
NUMBER TWO YES THE GOVERNOR DID
DID VETO THE BILL LAST YEAR- IN
HIS VETO MESSAGE HE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS OF SUCH AS THE FOLKS
AT TECHNET EXPRESS CONCERNING.
KOVIN TESTING AGAIN. IN COVERT
TESTING YOU'RE LOOKING AT A
DIFFERENT SEQUENCE TO LOOK AT A
DIFFERENT ITEM RNA VERSUS DNA.
OUT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T IN ANY
WAY AND HAVE IT. COBIT TESTING
WE THINK WE WILL SO WE WELL WE
THINK WE'VE GOTTEN THERE BUT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE EXTRA
MILE TO MAKE SURE GO THE EXTRA
MILE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
PROVIDE THE GOVERNOR THE KIND
OF ASSURANCE THAT THAT HE NEEDS
SO THAT HE CAN SIGN THE BILL.
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S PRIVACY
AND ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
NOT INTERFERE IN ANY WAY WITH
COVERT TESTING. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES IN THE OTHER- MEMBER
WISH TO SPEAK SEEING NONE I'LL
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL LAST YEAR. I
KIND OF WANT TO REHASH SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION BEFORE- LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN YOU JUST
BRIEFLY- OFFER A SUMMARY ON
WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ON
THIS MATTER AND WHAT TOOLS
STILL REMAIN AT THEIR DISPOSAL
EVEN EITHER BE A PROHIBITION ON
DISCLOSURES- LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN STILL. ACCESS THIS
INFORMATION- WITH FOR EXAMPLE A
COURT ORDER- THE CONCERN WOULD
BE THAT WHERE AN A AN ENTITY
WHO COLLECTS DNA ANALYZES DNA
AND TURNS OVER ITS WHOLESALE
DATABASE- WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
PROTECTIONS IN TERMS OF PRIVACY
AS YOU'LL NOTE I'VE NOT HEARD
ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IN
OPPOSITION- AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE PROVIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE NECESSARY TOOLS
TO CATCH SOMEONE LIKE THE
GOLDEN STATE KILLER BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THAT WHEN SOMEONE
SIGNS UP FOR A DIRECT TO
CONSUMER DNA TESTS THE THAT
THEY KNOW WHEN AND THE BODY
GIVEN CONSENT UP FRONT THAT THE
ENTITY CAN DISTRIBUTED TO
MEMBER THEY CHOOSE. BUT THAT
THEY KNOW WHERE THEIR. DNA IS
BEING DELIVERED. OKAY AND I
THINK- THE AGGREGATING
INFORMATION WHETHER IT BE DNA
OR- SUBSTANTIVE FACTUAL
INFORMATION NORMALLY FROM A
LEGAL STANDPOINT IT'S
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION THAT IS
OF GRAVE CONCERN SO WITH THIS
BILL CREATED A PROBLEM WHEN
INDIVIDUALS OR A COMPANY
COLLECTS DNA RELATED MATERIEL
INFORMATION IN AN AGGREGATED
FORMAT FOR OTHER MEDICAL
PURPOSES. AS LONG AS THERE'S NO
IDENTIFIER BY VIRTUE OF NAME OR
SOCIAL SECURITY IS THAT
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES STILL PRESENT
WITH US THE YES US AND BRITISH
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA ONE OF
OUR- GREAT RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS IN THE COUNTRY
MAYBE THE WORLD. IS IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE THEY WILL STILL HAVE
ACCESS TO NONSO DYNAMIS I THINK
THAT'S HOW I PRONOUNCE IT
EVERYONE PRONOUNCES IT
INFORMATION IN OTHER WORDS
INFORMATION THAT IS PROVIDED AS
YOU SUGGEST IN THE AGGREGATE
BUT NOT IDENTIFIED TO A
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL SO IT CAN'T
BE USED FOR. PURPOSES OF
DENYING HEALTH CARE PURPOSES OF
EMPLOYMENT THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS PERFECT IN MY LAST POINT
THIS IS MORE OF A GEO POLITICAL
POINT- THIS STILL KEEPS US.
MOVING FORWARD IN THE REALM OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE STILL
KEEPS US IN THE GAME EVEN
THOUGH AS WE- ARE FIGURING OUT
THE NEXT FRONTIER CERTAINLY
CHINA'S LEADING IN THIS REALM.
THIS TYPE OF INFORMATION IS
STILL HELPFUL AS WE MOVE INTO
THE REALM OF UNDERSTANDING
SEQUENCING AND- AND IN VARIOUS
BIOMETRIC ANALYSIS SO. THAT WAS
IT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT-
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE S.
HAS GOING FOR NUMBER THREE I'M
GOING TO Y. CASKEY HERE. ALL
RIGHTS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER WACO SKI- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND IN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
COUNCIL CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY I'M THIS IS SB FORTY
ONE BY SENATOR- BURKE. THE
MOTION IS BY SORRY I DIDN'T.
SENATOR WHY CASTING SENATOR
AKOWSKI THANK YOU DO PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AMBERG HI
AMBERG HI FORTUS BY BURGESS I
CARRY IT ON MY VERY AT ALL I
HIT US SO HI THE BEST SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ SUPPLY
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. LAYERED. SORRY IS HERE
OF HIS I. HERE OKAY STERN.
STERN AYE STERN I Y. CASKEY HI
MY CASKEY I. WIENER. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT
YOU HAVE EIGHT TO THERE BUT YOU
CAN HOLD THE ROLES OPEN RIGHT.
ZERO THE ROLE ROOM WILL REMAIN
OPEN THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SENATOR BORDERS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP- NEXT- CENTER LATELY
BEEN WAITING VERY PATIENTLY-
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING- SB SIXTY FOUR- FIRST
ARE YOU ACCEPT THE MEMBERS AS
OUTLINED IN ELSE'S ON PAGE
ELEVEN I AM- AND THEN SECONDLY
CENTER ATER THANK YOU FOR
BEING- SO DILIGENT WITH RESPECT
TO THIS ISSUE AND WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS
TO. FURTHER REFINE THE BILL
THANK YOU- WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
SENATORS CENTER LEYVA SB SIXTY
FOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I HAVE TO SAY THAT
SEVEN YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
APPOINTED THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE SUBCOMMITTEE ON A
MOBILE HOME MOBILE MANUFACTURED
HOMES. I DID NOT KNOW THAT
SEVEN YEARS LATER I WOULD STILL
BE JUST AS PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE BUT I AM AND I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DID NOT LET THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE KNOW HOW
MANY MOBILE HOME PARKS THEY
HAVE IN THEIR DISTRICT CENTER
I'M BIRD YOU HAVE EIGHTY SEVEN
PARKS WITH TWELVE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
SPACES. THAT ARE BORDERS YOU
HAVE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
PARTS WITH TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
SPACES THAT ARE CABALLERO YOU
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
PARKS WITH EIGHT THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE SPACES.
SENATOR DORADO YOU HAVE THE
LEAST WITH THREE PARKS AND
EIGHTY SPACES CENTER GONZALEZ
SIXTY SEVEN PARKS THREE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SPACES SENATOR HERTZBERG THIRTY
ONE PARKS THREE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX SPACES.
SENATOR STERN YOU HAVE FORTY
TWO PARKS FIVE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE SPACES
AND SENATOR WHITE HOUSE DO YOU
HAVE FIFTY TWO PARKS SEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SPACES. THE REASON I
LIKE TO DO THAT IS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES I THINK WE FORGET
ABOUT OUR MOBILE HOME PARKS AND
A MOBILE HOME PARK RESIDENTS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
PERSONALLY FOR BEING AN
ADVOCATE FOR MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS AT TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK IN
PROVIDING LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
CONFORM SB SIXTY ONE WITH THE
RECENTLY ENACTED SB NINETY ONE.
THAT PROVIDES A VICTIM
PROTECTION PROTECTIONS FOR
RESIDENTS. AFFECTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN. I LIKE TO BEGIN BY.
ALL THE MEN AND IN THE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION THAT
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL RENTAL
ASSISTANCE- REVISIT THE
PROVISION REGARDING REPAYMENT
OF RENT IN THIS BILL. WHAT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SB SIXTY
FOUR CREATES A PROTECTIVE
PROCESS FOR MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS IMPACTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN BY PREVENTING THE
MANAGEMENT OF MOBILE HOME PARKS
FROM TERMINATING OR ATTEMPTING
TO TERMINATE THE TENANCY OF
AFFECTED RESIDENTS DURING A
DECLARED STATE. OR LOCAL
EMERGENCY RELATED TO COVER
NINETEEN AS I NOTED WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE MIRRORING THE BILL TO
CONFORM TO SB NINETY ONE'S
EXISTING RENTAL PROTECTIONS FOR
RESIDENTS. HOWEVER SB NINETY
ONE DOES NOT COVER THE SEVEN
DAY NOTICE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE UNIQUE TO MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS AND WITHOUT
PROTECTIONS RESIDENTS COULD
FACE UNFAIR EVICTIONS. SB SIXTY
FOUR WOULD ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC
GAP IN SB NINETY ONE AND ALSO
PROTECT MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
FROM RETALIATORY RENT INCREASES
IN CALIFORNIA AS ALSO IN THE
CASE ACROSS THE COUNTRY. MOBILE
HOMES ARE IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ALTERNATIVE THAT ARE MAINLY
COMPRISED OF SENIORS VETERANS
IMMIGRANTS AND LOW INCOME
FAMILIES CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA
LAW DEFINES MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS AS BOTH OWNERS AND
TENANTS. BECAUSE IN SOME CASES
THE RESIDENT OWNS THE ACTUAL
MOBILE HOME BUT THE PARK OWNS
THE LAND UNDERNEATH THE MOBILE
HOME. THE PROVISION IN THE LAW
ACTUALLY GIVES MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS A GREATER POTENTIAL
FOR LOSS EVERY TRADITIONAL
APARTMENT. OR HOME RESIDENTS
WERE EVICTED THEY CAN PACK UP
AND LEAVE BUT THE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENT WOULD ACTUALLY LOSE IN
SOME CASES THEIR BIGGEST ASET
THEIR HOME VALUED MANY TIMES
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS AND EVEN HIGHER. SB
SIXTY FOUR WOULD ADDRESS THE
SPECIFIC GAP THAT LEAVES MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS AT RISK FOR
INFECTION ULTIMATELY GIVING
THEM A GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO
REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES. SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT TODAY SB SIXTY FOUR
IS STATE MAY. HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE
PRESENT. LYNDON NINE IN ON THE
LINE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
BRUCE STANTON ATTORNEY FOR G.
S. M. O. L. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU CENTROLEGAL LIMIT LET ME
UNDERLINE SOMETHING YOU IT SAID
THAT WE ARE OPERATING UNDER THE
PRESUMPTION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL PERMIT RENTAL
ASSISTANCE BE PROVIDED FOR
THOSE IN MOBILE HOME PARKS-
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A BENEFIT TO
BOTH OF THOSE RESIDENTS AS WELL
AS A PARK OWNERS. SHOULD THIS
NOT HAPPEN THEN WE HAVE TO
REVISIT THIS BILL I AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE FULLY
SUPPORT OF US REVISITING THE
BILL IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHOULD NOT HIM BUT WE HAVE NO
INDICATION THAT IT IS NOT GOING
TO BE COVERED. BUT WE HAVE NOT
GOTTEN A CLEAR STATEMENT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS
POINT SO- NOW TURNING SIXTY
WITNESSES I BELIEVE MISS NIGHT
IS ON THE PHONE- WELL- LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY AND SUPPORT. KNOWN
AS SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NOT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- NOW
WILL GO TO MISS NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LINDA NOT. FINE
PRESIDENT OF CABLE SHE HAD HIM
AWHILE. THANK YOU KNOW JERRY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SENIOR
VETERAN IMMIGRANTS ARE LIVING
IN THE STATE'S LARGEST STOCK OF
MODERN AFFORDABLE HOME. THESE
ARE MANUFACTURED AND MOBILE
HOMES. WITH THE STATE HOUSING
CRISIS AND A GLOBAL PANDEMIC WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO SENATOR LEAHY
NOT FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THE
BILL. I WANT TO CLARIFY. MUCH
OF THE UNFAIR AND UNFORTUNATE
MISREPRESENTATIONS FOR THE
GANDER WORK WITH AN ATTORNEY
ABOUT LAST YEAR SHE DIDN'T FEEL
IS NOT A HAND OUT. IT PROVIDES
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON FIXED INCOMES
WHO AND WHO ARE LOW INCOME OR
WAIT TO SEE THEIR WAY OUT OF
TODAY'S ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. THE BILL ONLY
COVERS THOSE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS WERE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
AND IT FEELS WHAT THE GOVERNOR
AND OTHERS MAY HAVE LEFT OUT.
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS ARE
GOVERNED BY SPECIFIC SECTIONS
CIVIL CODE SECTION. WE DO THIS
BILL AND THE COMMITTEE DID
MANAGE LIKE OURSELVES MODEST
AND REASONABLE. THE BILL IS A
SMALL GUIDING LIGHT TO HELP
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS FIND
THEIR WAY TO A BRIGHTER LIGHT
AT THE END OF THIS LONG DARK
TUNNEL. WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MISS NINE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
CENTER LEYVA NO SIR NO ALL
RIGHT AND WE'VE GONE TO THE
GALLERY GOING TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO NOW- IF WE COULD GO
TO THE PHONES TO SEE IF THERE
ARE OTHER WITNESSES. VETERANS
SUPPORT JUST AS A REMINDER YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION- IN YOUR
POSITION. MISTER MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES WHICH
TESTIFIED TELEPHONICALLY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW NO NO ONE- WAIT A
COMMON ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATE WE'RE NOT GONNA
TURN THE OPPOSITION- I SEE
MISTER GOVERNOR WHO IS-
PATIENTLY WAITING UP IN THE
GALLERY MISTER GOVERNOR. THANK
YOU SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ENTER GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATESON
BEHALF OF W. I MAY END OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THIS
BILL DOES NOT AFFECT RENTAL
PAYMENTS MADE BY MOBILE HOME
PARK RESIDENTS YOU WILL COVER
THAT THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT SB
NINETY ONE IN AB EIGHTY ONE.
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE CERES
SECTION OF LAW THAT GIVES A
SEVEN DAY NOTICES FOR RULES AND
REGULATION VIOLATIONS. THIS IS
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR ALL MOBILE
HOME PARK RESIDENTS. IT WAS A
SENATOR AS THAT AS CENTER LEYVA
SAID YOU WILL HAVE ALL OF THOSE
RESIDENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT IF
YOU VOTE FOR THIS BILL YOU MAY
BE HELPING ONE RESIDENT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY AFFECTING THE QUALITY
OF LIFE OF EVERY RESIDENT IN A
PARK. AND LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT
THE TIMELINE OF A SEVEN DAY
NOTICE NO ONE IS GOING TO BE
MADE HOMELESS IF THEY GET A
SEVEN DAY NOTICE. YOU ISSUE A
SEVEN DAY NOTICE SEVEN DAYS GO
BY YOU THEN ISSUE A SIXTY DAY
NOTICE. YOU THEN HAVE TO ISSUE
AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER AFTER THAT
A JUDGE RULES YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A MINIMUM OF THREE TO FOUR
MONTHS BEFORE SOMEONE HAS TO
ADDRESS OUR RULES AND
REGULATIONS. MAYBE IT'S HAVING
ONE TOO MANY DOGS MAYBE IT'S
HAVING TRASH ON THE PROPERTY.
WITHIN THE BILL HOPPERS A SAFE
HARBOR FOR SERIOUS VIOLATIONS
THE PROBLEM IS THAT'S AN
ILLUSORY SAFE HARBOR BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE FOUR LINE
SIXTEEN. THE JUDGE ONLY LOOKS
TO SEE IF IT'S A SERIOUS
VIOLATION AFTER THE U. D. HAS
BEEN FILED WHICH IS AFTER A
MINIMUM OF SEVENTY DAYS. WHICH
MEANS THAT EVERY RESIDENT IN
YOUR PARK IS LIVING NEXT TO A
HAZARDOUS SITUATION A VIOLENT
OFFENDER OR SOMEBODY THAT IS
HARMING THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT
RENT. IN ADDITION IF WE DON'T
HAVE INJUNCTIVE RELIEF ON DAY
ONE HOW ARE WE SUPPOSED TO THEN
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS ARE
PROTECTED. SO REALLY THIS IS AN
ILLUSORY SAFE HARBOR IT AFFECTS
ALL RESIDENTS IN THE PARK AND
WE GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE IN
CENTER DOLLARS DISTRICT IN A
SENIOR PARK. AN ADULT SON.
ADULT SON. WITH THEIR REQUEST
FOUND IS RUNNING CAR WITH USED
WE NEED. BODY RMOR. ARE IN AN-
WE ISSUE A SEVENTY. FOR THAT
PERSON TO VACATE. THE WOMAN
KICKED HER SON OUT CAME AND
THANK THE MANAGEMENT. BECAUSE
WITHOUT THAT SEVENTY NOTED SHE
WOULD HAVE A HARD TIME PICKING
UP HER SON. WHY DOES THAT
PERSON NEED A YEAR TO RECTIFY
KICKING OUT HER SON WHO MIGHT
BE TERRORIZING EVERYONE IN THE
PARK. FOR THESE REASONS AND
OTHERS WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU MR
GOVERNOR- MISTER MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE- ON WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IT THE
CHICKEN CHAIN'S IN AKRON I
APOLOGIZE FOR CONFUSING THING
BUT I'M ON A SEPARATE LINE AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO OFFER MY
COMMENTS NOW IF YOU'D LIKE. WE
HAVE- TWO WITNESSES IF YOU
HAVE. AN OPPOSITION OPPOSITION.
YES SIR OKAY GO AHEAD GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT CHANGED AMERICA
WITH I DON'T THINK YOU'LL EVER
ROPES AND SPENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE. BUT SIMILARLY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY FOUR
UNCLES PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT MR
GOVERNOR MAINTAINED AND AGREE
WITH SO. MANY ANALYSIS. FROM
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF OUR
GOVERNOR'S QUALITY BILLION
FIRST COMPLAINED TO PARK RULES
OR TO TRY TO PROTECTION IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL. MISTER CHAIR
IT'S NOT JUST IMPORTANT IN THE
PENSIONS WILL BECAUSE ASISTIR
GOVERNOR DESCRIBED SEVENTY
NOTICE AND DON'T JUST ADDRESS.
MINOR ISSUES LIKE LANDSCAPING
AND MAINTENANCE THE INTEREST
YOUR INSTALLATION SUCH AS THE
ONE HE DESCRIBES THINGS RELATED
TO REPEATING VANDALISM ARSON
AND BURGLARY- AND SB SIXTY FOUR
WILL TAKE THAT TO THE TABLE AND
PROHIBITED ACTION FOR ANY
RESIDENTS IMPACTED BY COLBERT
NINETEEN BUT THAT IS VERY
BROADLY DEFINED IN THIS BILL.
AND AS MR GOVERNOR DESCRIBED.
WELCOME THAT IS. IT'S A- NOT
JUST RESIDENTS WHO HAVE BY THE
BUT THE OTHER RATHER WERE
AROUND THE VIOLATE- THE STATE
FARM PROVISION IN THE BILL.
WHAT OTHER INTENDED TO ALLOW
PARKING TO IN. THEM SEVEN
MILLION- IT'S AN TO LOOK AT THE
LINK ITSELF WHICH- THE WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR ENFORCEMENT OF
A- TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC NEWS.
IN HAZARD. ASSET FOR CAN HELP
THINKING SECTION ONE EIGHT YEAR
THE PROBLEM IS THAT HELP SAFETY
SECTION DOESN'T THE- WHAT
IMMINENT HAZARD WERE PREPARED
PUBLIC NUISANCE. SO APART OWNER
FOR HIMSELF A TWO. WHERE THEY
BELIEVE THEIR OTHER PARK RIGHT
ARE THAT YOUR- THEY'RE GOING
HAVE TO GO TO COURT IN. BACK
QUITE BEFORE THEY CAN PER ONE
ON DETAINER WHICH PASSED THE
TIME TO THE THREE TO FOUR
MONTHS PRIOR WITH MISTER
GOVERNOR INSCRIBED IN A- LAW
ENFORCING AFFECT DAY NOTE. THAT
ADDITIONAL NEEDS MORE TIME FOR
RESIDENTS LIVING NEXT TO
NUISANCE INCLUDING THOSE RATHER
PRESIDENT. GORE ALSO IMPACTED
BY COVERT NINETEEN AND SIMPLY
TRYING TO GET BY THANK YOU SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE RISK.
WHERE SPECTACLE TECHNICALLY FOR
A QUESTIONABLE ALREADY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR- OTHERS ON
THE PHONE OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR I ONE. WAITING TO. IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD LOT BED LINE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THE SEARCH CARE MEMBERS
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. IF NOT WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE FLOOR. QUESTIONS
ON THE FLOOR OF CENTER GORGEOUS.
THE RESEARCHER OF IF I MAY POSE
A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
CENTER LABEL YES SO AND I KNOW
THAT THIS- THIS BILL HAS SOME
HISTORY TO IT BUT I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD HELP
UNDERSTAND HELP ME UNDERSTAND-
THE DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
MEANING THAT IF A INDIVIDUAL
COULD NOT HEY TO GET REPAIRS
DONE AND SO ON AND SO FORTH-
WHAT EXACTLY IS THE
ATTESTATION. IS UNDER PENALTY
OF PERJURY. THE ACTUAL MOBILE
HOME RESIDENT THEY HAVE TO
ATTEST THAT THEY COULDN'T
REALLY OKAY REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THE RESIDENTS HAVE
TIME TO PAY TO FIX THE PROBLEMS
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN CITED IS
THAT WHAT YOUR QUESTION WAS
REGARDING YEAH NO I UNDERSTAND
I THINK IT'S UP TO A YEAR TO
FIX THESE THINGS BUT I THINK
THE IDEA WAS- BECAUSE OF. THIS
IS CODE RELATED A LOT OF FOLKS
IS FINANCES ARE IN PERIL SO I
GUESS THE IDEA IS GOING BACK TO
WHAT WE LEARNED ON WAS IT SB
NINETY ONE WHICH WAS THE
EXTENSION OF THE LANDLORD
TENANT THE TENANT ISSUE IS THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAD TO ATTEST
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY. FATAL
LACKED THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
BECAUSE OF CODE AND PROVIDE
SOME DEGREE OF DOCUMENTATION TO
WHATEVER IS RELEVANT AT THE
TIME DOES THIS HAVE THAT SAME
LEVEL OF EXPECTATION THAT'S
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY THEY
HAVE TO SHOW THAT THE REASON
THAT THEY CANNOT MAKE THE
BUT IS IT UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY I HONESTLY DO NOT KNOW
AS IT AS A AS A I MENTIONED IS
GOING TO BRING THIS UP WOULD
YOU CONSIDER AS A AS AN
AMENDMENT ADDING THIS- TO THE
REQUIREMENT OF THE BILL AS A
FRIENDLY AMENDMENT. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SIR
FOR JUST I BELIEVE CENTERS. HAS
IS FOR HE UP SO SOME WE COULD
TURN TO SENATOR STERN IS THAT
CORRECT CENTER STERN. YOU ARE
CORRECT MISTER CHAIR LET ME
TAKE MY VIRTUAL HAND DOWN.
SORRY. BUT WE CAN'T YES WE HEAR
YOU. OKAY GREAT- IT'S FOR THE
CONVERSATION I GUESS EIGHT I
JUST NOW READING THROUGH THE-
YEAH THE STAFF ANALYSIS- AND I
HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE
PROVISION THAT WAS JUST BEING.
NOT THE ONE SENATOR BOARD JUST
BROUGHT UP BUT THIS. THIS SORT
OF PROCEDURALLY WATCHED WHAT
THE AUTHOR ANTICIPATES. DO YOU
WANT FOLKS TO HAVE TO GO TO
THAT COURT HEARING IS ARE YOU
SORT OF SIXTY THAT IS THERE A
MORE EXPEDITED REVIEW OF SOME
SORT THAT YOU CAN- THE- YOU ALL
ARE OPEN TO. IN TERMS OF. THE
LOOKING AT THOSE NUISANCE IS AN
IMMINENT HAZARDS ARE JUST
THINKING ALL THE PEOPLE GOT
BURNT OUT FOR INSTANCE IN ALL A
BUNCH OF OUR MOBILE HOMES IN
THE DISTRICT AND- IT'S BEEN
BRUTAL LIKE DEALING WITH. I
DON'T KNOW. DREDGING ALL THE
ACTION ALL THESE ARE DIFFERENT
ISSUES NEIGHBORS FIGHTING WITH
NEIGHBORS SO I JUST. CAN CAN
YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF YOUR
INTENT AT LEAST WITH THAT IS
IT. IS IT THE CASE THAT YOU
WANT TO GO TO COURT FOR THAT
KIND OF ISSUE OR- DID YOU HAVE
A DIFFERENT INTENDING YOU THINK
THE OPPONENTS ARE SORT OF MIS
CHARACTERIZING THAT THAT.
DEFINITELY THINK USERS ARE
DEFINITELY THINK THE OPPONENTS
ARE MIS CHARACTERIZING A LOT OF
THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY SB SIXTY
FOUR STATES THAT RESIDENTS
CANNOT INVOKE. THREE
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL IN THE
CASE OF FIRE SAFETY FIRE
ENFORCEMENT OR ANYTHING THAT
POSES AN IMMEDIATE RISK OF LIFE
HEALTH OR SAFETY. OF THE PUBLIC
OR THE OCCUPANTS THIS IS NOT A
BLANKET WAIVER OF RULES THIS IS
COVE IN SPECIFIC. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. IT DOES-
AND THEN THE PROCEED THE
PROCESS WISE JUST IN THE NITTY
GRITTY DO YOU WANT. IF
SOMEONE'S MAKING IF THE I GUESS
OF THE OWNERS SAYING OKAY THIS
IS AN INTEREST INSTANCE OF A
NEW SENSOR FIRE SAFETY ISSUE
ALL THE ALL THE THINGS YOU JUST
MENTIONED. SHOULD THEY GO TO
WHAT'S THERE WHAT'S THE
RECOURSE THEN WHAT ARE THEY
SUPPOSED TO DO THERE'S- THAT
DID THEY GO TO TRY TO SEEK AN
INJUNCTION. OPPONENTS WERE
SAYING THEY CAN'T GET AN
INJUNCTION SO WHAT HOW DO THEY
ENFORCE THAT PROVISION. WE'RE
ACTUALLY MY OFFICE IS WORKING
WITH THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
STAFF AS WELL TO DO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION. OKAY GREAT SO
YOU'LL YOU'LL KEEP US POSTED ON
THAT. SUBJECT IT OKAY VERY GOOD
THANKS FOR THE INPUT THERE
THANK YOU. FOR IT THANK YOU
SINISTER AND ANY OTHER MEMBERS
SENATORS HAVE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. ON NOW- COMING BACK
TO COMING BACK TO THE FLOOR I
SEEING NONE. I HAVE A QUESTION
I UNDERSTAND THAT ONE OF THE
WITNESSES ATTESTING IT DESPITE
OPPOSITION MENTION ARSONISTS
AND BURGLARS WHAT WOULD THAT
COME UNDER THE- ISSUE THE
PROVISION CONCERNING SERIOUS
SAFETY CONCERNS ABSOLUTELY ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU CERTAINLY
REDUCE YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU
CENTER AMBERG THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION I
JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT THIS BILL WAS ON THIS
FLOOR PASSED OFF OF THIS FOR
PASSED UP THE ASSEMBLY FOR WAS
HERE ON CONCURRENCE. AND WAS
NOT ABLE TO GET TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK BECAUSE IT WAS
NOT APPROVED BOB BROUGHT UP
BEFORE MIDNIGHT ON THE LAST DAY
OF SESSION. WE ARE A YEAR INTO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THERE ARE STILL MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO HELP
THOSE FOLKS. I WOULD HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT THE OPPOSITION
SAID I HOPE THAT I CLEARED SOME
OF THAT UP IN ANSWERING SENATOR
STERN'S QUESTION AND THE
VIOLENT OFFENDER THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP BY OPPOSITION. THAT
IS ALSO COVERED IN THIS BILL
AND SB SIXTY FOUR DOES NOT
AFFECT THIS THIS IS SIMPLY
HELPING PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
AFFECTED BY COVERT NINETEEN
STATE IN OUR MOBILE HOME. HOME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO I
RESPECT ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
THANK YOU. MA'AM COUNSEL IF
YOU'D CALL THE ROLL. L. O. WE
NEED A MOTION YES- SENATORS ARE
MOST. WAIT A MINUTE. OKAY
SENATORS COULD YOU PLEASE TURN
YOUR MICROPHONES ON THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. AND
THIS IS S. B. SIXTY FOR YOU
GUYS DO PASSED AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION.
LAMBERG HI I'M BURKE I BORJAS
NO PORGES NO CABALLERO HI KELLY
AT ALL I DID ALSO I DID US SO
HI GONZALEZ I. GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES. LAYERED STERN JOHN I.
STERN I A WHITE HOUSE GARY BYE
BYE CASKEY I WIENER HI. WIENER
HI SO RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE. THREE
SIX SEVEN EIGHT TO ONE BUT YOU
GET A HOLD OF IT WE'RE GONNA
EIGHT TO ONE WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN HOWEVER
THIS IS THE LAST MATTER TO COME
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
COMING UP NOW. SO MISTER
TERRIFIC MEMBERS. THANK YOU SIR
LEYVA SO- IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
WHO WISH TO VOTE. ON THE ITEMS
THAT WE CONSIDER TODAY THEY
SHOULD CONSIDER COMING TO THE
CHAMBER HERE IF THEY COME NOW
OPEN THE ROLE AND EVERYTHING
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN- VOTED
UPON. BUT NOT CONCLUDED ALL
RIGHT- I BELIEVE NOW WE HAVE S.
R. SIX SENATE RESOLUTION NUMBER
SIX. AND PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR SKINNER IS A SINNER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION SIX ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR SKINNER WHICH
COMMEMORATES. JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS THE%
FORTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF ROE
V. WADE. IT'S BEEN FORTY YEARS
SINCE THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
RULED IN ROE V. WADE THAT A
WOMAN'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY INCLUDES A RIGHT TO
ABORTION. BEFORE ROE V. WADE AN
ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO MILLION
WOMEN RESORTED TO ILLEGAL
ABORTION EVERY YEAR. UNSAFE
ABORTIONS BECAUSE AS MANY AS
FIVE THOUSAND ANNUAL DEATHS AND
WOMEN OF COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY AT RISK. AS
THEY WERE MORE LIKELY TO LACK
THE FUNDS TO TRAVEL TO AN AREA
OF THE COUNTRY WERE SAFE
ABORTIONS WERE BEING PERFORMED.
MANY OF THE ECONOMIC AND RACIAL
DIVIDES PERSIST TODAY AS STATES
CONTINUE TO CHIP AWAY AT
WOMEN'S ACCESS TO LEGAL
ABORTION. WHILE MOST STATES.
ARE RESTRICTING WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
FEW PASSING LEGISLATION TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AS OF NOW. THAT'S
CONGRESS AND STATE LEGISLATURES
ACROSS AMERICA CONSIDER POLICY
IN WOMEN'S HEALTH IT'S CRITICAL
TO LISTEN TO DOCTORS AND
MEDICAL EXPERTS WHO KNOW THAT
LEGAL ABORTION IS SAFE. AND TO
VOTERS WHO WANT POLITICIANS TO
STOP INTERFERING WITH THEIR
PERSONAL MEDICAL DECISIONS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE MUST HIGHLIGHT
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF ROE V. WADE
AND CONTINUE TO ACT NOW AS A
STATE IN ORDER TO PROTECT.
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM AND LOOK
AT POLICIES THAT PROVIDE
ABORTION ACCESS TO ALL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
ON AS FAR SIX. THANK YOU US
SENATE GONZALEZ- AND WE'RE
GONNA TURN OUT TO WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND MISS MOLLY ROBSON
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES CALIFORNIA IS ON THE
LINE- BEFORE WE TAKE TESTIMONY
LET ME JUST REMIND. THOSE WHO
MAY BE ON THE PHONE. THAT WE
WILL HAVE TO WITNESSES IF
PRESENT. IN SUPPORT TO MEANT TO
WITNESS AS OPPOSED TO MINUTES
EACH. AND THEN TO THE EXTENT
THE FOLKS ARE ON THE LINE.
YOU'LL BE PERMITTED TO TESTIFY
AS TO YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
SO MISTER MODERATOR IF MISS
ROBSON IS THERE WE ASK THAT YOU
TO CONNECT FOR. HI SHOW THAT
SHE IS CONNECTED. THANK YOU
THIS ROBSON. I THINK YOU GOT
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS MY
RIBS AND I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES CLIFORNIA
REPRESENTING WITHOUT IN
PREPARED AND AFFILIATES PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE FOR OVER A HUNDRED
HEALTH CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I WANT TO THANK CENTER
CENTER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
OFFERING THIS RESOLUTION
CONSIDERED INVOLVED PRESENTING.
THIS RESOLUTION CELEBRATE THE
FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
HISTORIC WILL BE RAISED IN
COURT DECISION WHICH PROTECTS
THE RIGHT AND ACCESS TO
ABORTION IN THE UNITED STATES
ALWAYS CELEBRATE THIS
ANNIVERSARY WE MUST ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FOR MANY
FORCING THIS BILL- RIGHT NAME
ONLY WITH A NEW FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION AND HER SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
CONGRESS. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REIMAGINE THE
FUTURE SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE THE REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM CONTINUES TO BE UNDER
THREAT. AMY CONEY BARRETT'S
CONFIRMATION TO THE SUPREME
COURT LAST YEAR SOLIDIFIED AT
COURT THAT REMAIN HOSTILE TO
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND THAT
THE PORTION ACCESS NATIONALLY
AT GREAT RISK WITH EIGHTEEN
CASES JUST ONE STEP AWAY FROM
THE SUPREME COURT WHICH COULD A
ROAD OR ELIMINATE THE
PROTECTION GRANTED BY ROW.
WE'RE FORTUNATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE LEADERS WHO
STAND REPLACE PARENTHOOD AND
UNDERSTAND THAT ABORTION CARE
IS HEALTH CARE. BUT THE LEGAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION ISN'T ENOUGH
TO THINK USE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FOR CONTINUING
TRANSACTIONS ACTUALLY AFFECTED
HEALTHCARE IN SEEKING WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT ACCESS TO ABORTION
IS A REALITY FOR ALL PEOPLE
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
AWARENESS FOR THE TRANSLATION
AND WHAT PROJECTS FOR AFTER SIX
AND ASK. FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
ROBSON. OF ANY OTHER WAY. AND I
SEE NOT IN THE IN THE GET. MAY
IF WE COULD TO ONE. NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE. ALL RIGHT- WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE SO
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES AND- IF
WE COULD IF I COULD ASK YOU TO
GIVE ME AN ESTIMATE AS THE
NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO ARE WISHING
TO TESTIFY. I WOULD BE GRATEFUL.
YES EDICARE FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE THE
BEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THE NEW ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR I SHOW AND KNOW PEOPLE
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOT TURN THE
OPPOSITION- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NONE HERE IN
THE GALLERY- I SAW NONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE THAT WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER MODERATOR. YOUR COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN. ZERO AND MISTER CHAIR
I SHOW NO ONE- WAITING TO
PROVIDE COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHTS- MISS- GONZALEZ DO
YOU CARE TO CLOSE. MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT WELL I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T I DIDN'T TURN TO THE-
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED- MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL. I'M SORRY I MISSPOKE
THE RESOLUTION HAS BEEN MOVED-
MEXICO CITY CALL THE ROLL. AWAY
THE MOTION. MADE THE MOTION- MR
WHITE HOUSE SPEECH GOT IT OKAY.
THANK YOU I'M MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI THIS IS S. R.
SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER THE V.
ADAPTED ORDERED FORTY THIRD
READING- BURKE HI NUMBER I
FORGES YEAH. PORTIS NOT VOTING
CABALLERO HI SEVEN ZERO I DID
ALSO I DID US SO HI GONZALEZ HI
AND SO. HI HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. LAYERED ON
LAYERED I STERN. STRONACH STERN
I Y. CASKEY HI MY CASKEY HI
WIENER HI WIENER I. YEAH NINE
AND THEN YOU CAN CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS SO THE VOTE RIGHT NOW
IS NINE- ZERO WITH ONE
ABSTENTION SO- WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN NOW IT IS
TWO FORTY FIVE WILL KEEP IT
OVER UNTIL TWO FIFTY SO- AT TWO
FIFTY WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
ROLE.
ALL RIGHT- WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE- WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN AGAIN FOR A FEW
MINUTES AFTER. THIS ROLL CALL
SO. LET LET ME BEGIN WITH
CONSENT CALENDAR- MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL ON THE- CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AT YES SO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS FOUR AND FIVE.
JONES. OKAY WE'RE STILL GONNA
PULL THAT UP ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WILL WILL GO TO- ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. TWENTY FOUR. M. S. B.
TWENTY FOUR D. PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. JONES WIENER
FIVE WIENER I KNOW HOLD IT OPEN
FOR JONES RIGHT NEXT OF MANAGED
ACCOUNTS WILL CALL THE ROLL ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FORTY ONE SB
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR UMBERG DAY
PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES LAYERED BY LAYERED AYE
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE THAT'S
TEN ZERO STILL NEED SENATOR
JONES ALL RIGHT- WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB SIXTY
FOUR. K. SB SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LEYVA THAT STEEP PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. JONES LAYERED
BY LAYERED I- THAT'S HOLDING
THAT OPEN. RIGHT GEN LESLIE-
ITEM NUMBER SIX S. R. SENATE
RESOLUTION NUMBER SIX S. R.
SIX- THIS IS MISTER JONES IS AB
FORTIS NOT VOTING- AND THEN
JONES ALL RIGHT WELL HOLD IT
OPEN ALL RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN HERE FOR JUST ANOTHER
FEW MINUTES IF WE COULD FIND
OUT WHAT THE STATUS IS TO
MISTER JONES THAT WOULD BE
USEFUL.
ALL RIGHT- WE WILL COME
BACK TO ORDER- WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE FOR THE CENTERS WERE
NOT PRESENT EARLIER. SO MADAM
BENNETT CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU'LL
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS FOUR AND FIVE
JONES HI. JONES HI THAT'S
ELEVEN TO ZERO LEVEL ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. RIGHT YEAH I KNOW
THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL RIGHT ITEM
NUMBER- ONE S. B. TWENTY FOUR-
MADAM SHE KEPT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HI THIS IS SB TWENTY FOUR
COLORADO DAY PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES HI.
THAT IS ELEVEN TWO ZERO. THE
BILL'S OUTLET ZERO NEXT IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. FORTY ONE
NUMBER. THIS SB FORTY ONE BY
CENTER- BURKE. DEEP PASSES
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR JONES.
NOT SURE ABOUT THIS ONE A
MINUTE TO THINK ABOUT THIS AND
FOR A LITTLE WHILE. HI SENATOR
JONES HI. THAT'S ELEVEN TO
ZERO. LEAD BILL IS OUT. NEXT
PLEASE CALL RULE ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB SIXTY FOUR. THIS IS SB
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR LABOR DAY
PASSES AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS JONES NO.
CHANCE NO YOU HAVE ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHTY OF NINETY TO NINETY TWO
THE BILL IS OUT GEN NEXT PLEASE
CALL ON THE FINAL ITEM ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATE RESOLUTION
NUMBER SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER
BE ADOPTED ORDERED. ORDERED TO
THIRD READING. SENATOR JONES-
NO SENATOR JOHN SNOW THAT. FOUR
SIX NINE IT'S NINE TWO ONE THE
RESOLUTION IS PASSED NINE TO
ONE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE ON THIS
SITE- INDEED UP HAVING TAKE A
PRESENT A BILL AT THE EXACT
SAME TIME YOU'RE WRAPPING UP SO
I WILL TRY TO MANAGE TO
COMMITTEES BETTER NEXT TIME
WELL THANK YOU SIR JOHN STUFF
HAPPENS SO- WE'RE WE'RE
ADJOURNED UNTIL. NEXT WEEK
THANK YOU.